Let's try to evaluate 7
and 6/9 minus 3 and 2/5.
So like always, I like to
separate out the whole number
parts from the fractional parts.
This is the same thing as 7
plus 6/9 minus 3 minus 2/5.
And the reason why I'm
saying minus 3 minus 2/5
is this is the same thing
as minus 3 plus 2/5.
And so you distribute
the negative sign.
You're subtracting a 3, and
then you're subtracting the 2/5.
And so now we can worry
about the whole number
parts, 7 minus 3.
Well, 7 minus 3 is
going to give us 4.
So that's going to give us 4.
And then we're going
to have 6/9 minus 2/5.
So let me think about
what 6/9 minus 2/5 are.
6/9 minus 2/5, well,
we're going to have
to find a common denominator.
So this is going to
be the same thing.
And I think the least
common multiple of 9 and 5
is going to be 45.
Literally, you then multiply.
They have no common factors.
So it's going to be over 45.
To go from 9 to 45, I
have to multiply by 5.
So I'm going to have to
multiply the numerator by 5.
So 6 times 5 is 30.
Then I'm going to subtract.
To go from 5 to 45, I
had to multiply by 9.
So I have to multiply
the numerator by 9
if I don't want to
change the value.
So 2 times 9 is 18.
And 30/45 minus 18/45 is
going to be something over 45.
30 minus 18 is 12.
If I subtract these two
fractions right over here,
I get 12/45.
So it's 4 plus 12/45.
Or if we wanted to write
it as a mixed number,
this is equal to 4 and 12/45.
But we're not done yet.
We can simplify this further.
12 and 45 have common factors.
They're both divisible by 3.
Actually, they're both
divisible by-- well,
I think we can divide
more after that.
So let's see.
If we divide the numerator by
3 and the denominator by 3,
we end up with 4.
And 12 divided by 3 is 4.
And 45 divided by 3 is 15.
4 and 4/15.
And actually, we're done.
These two can't be
simplified anymore.
4 and 4/15.